[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
derek shovin makes his first federal
court appearance following his
conviction for the murder of george
floyd
why the former cop is now in isolation
behind bars
sean stakes larkin joins us to talk
about his new book on wrongfully accused
cops
and to share his own story about his
time on the tulsa police force
plus a sneak preview into the latest
show about criminal trials
court cam presents under oath this is
really
telling you how we got there as well as
the defendant's decision to take the
stand and will a shocking jailhouse call
come in as evidence in the tennessee
trial
of a father accused of murdering his
five-year-old son i'm not telling the
whole story either yet
plus a retired nypd detective defends
his investigation
into the still unsolved disappearance of
the wife of a millionaire real estate
heir
the testimony in the robert durst trial
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
former minneapolis police officer derek
shovin makes his first appearance in
federal court
and says he can't afford to hire a
lawyer long crime's anjanette levy is
here with what happened at chauvin's
hearing
yeah brian derek shovin will remain
behind bars until his trial on federal
civil rights charges he didn't contest
his detention
referring to what he called his current
circumstances
the last time we saw derek chauvin
sheriff's deputies led him out of the
courtroom in handcuffs after he
was found guilty of unintentional murder
in george floyd's death
as he sits in prison in isolation
chauvin is now accused of violating
floyd's rights
and the rights of a 14 year old boy if
the police officer
knew what the constitutional rights were
and acted excessively
anyway that's the crime that is charged
in this case
former u.s attorney ben glassman
explained the basis for the charge
chauvin was a police officer when he
kneeled on george floyd's neck
he's also accused of hitting a 14 year
old boy in the head with a flashlight
during a domestic violence call
and kneeling on him too eric nelson the
defense attorney who represented chauvin
at his trial on state charges
has been appointed by the federal court
to represent chauvin
because he claims he's indigent the fact
he's not working now
and presumably going to prison pretty
much makes almost anybody indigent
defense attorney jay clark says derek
chovin had to present information to the
court about his finances to be declared
indigent
and have taxpayers pay nelson to
represent him
it makes sense he knows the case better
than
anybody at the time could know which
means the case can be prepared and move
along faster
now the minnesota police and peace
officers association
paid for chauvin's legal bills in his
state case i contacted that organization
and a spokesperson told me that she had
no comment
when i asked why the organization wasn't
paying for his representation in the
federal case as well
brian thanks anjanet joining us today is
sean stick's larkin retired
tulsa police sergeant and host of the
podcast cocktails
along with terry austin shot back and
forth from state to federal courts
what do you imagine transporting an
officer convicted of murder like this
is like you know it's going to be
uncomfortable for
the officers the deputies the marshals
everybody involved
i myself was involved in an arrest here
in tulsa several years ago
we actually had to arrest an officer on
duty and just that
alone is so uncomfortable uh you know
chauvin is
in a negative way i guess probably the
most well-known police officer in the
country at least right now
and so for everybody involved in that
transportation they understand that they
are going to be under scrutiny they're
going to be watched
uh it's going to be on the cameras and
uh it's just going through the motion
for these guys
you know let's hope they're definitely
safe and no one's targeting them there
don't want that to happen of course
terry eric nelson does know a lot about
the case
but could it be better to have a i don't
know another pair of eyes on this case
as we go to another step in the trial
listen i would want someone who knows
the case inside
and out but in a perfect world you know
a defendant would have
someone who knows the case plus someone
who has a fresh pair of eyes
but a right to a fair trial definitely
does not include unlimited funding for
representation
now anjanet we do provide uh criminal
defense
for individuals if they can't afford it
myself being a public defender
but do you know how much defending a
case like this could cost in federal
court
you know i asked around and say that
derek chovin
had unlimited funds and he could pay for
a lawyer
i talked to jay clark about this for
instance and he said that this defense
in federal court would cost at least six
figures he
guessed that a retainer alone would be
250 000
and he said well think about it even if
it was a hundred thousand dollars that's
still a lot of money for somebody to
come up with
so it would be incredibly expensive he
said just because of the amount of work
that goes into it
and the high profile nature of the case
yeah that of course would be
for someone to retain if there's a
defense attorney maybe probably much
less i know the cja or the federal panel
pays about 150 190 depending on if it's
capital
or non-capital so we'll keep eyes on
that now
don't go anywhere sean because i know
you have a new book coming out
about your experience as a law
enforcement officer breaking blue tells
real stories of cops accused of
wrongdoing
and subsequently cleared larky even
shares his own story
breaking blue will be released on june
15th and is available for pre-order now
sticks i've got ass let's get right to
it tell us about when you were
wrongfully accused
oh well unfortunately there's several
different incidents some small in size
some much larger but the one i focus on
here in the book
started in 2009 there was a federal
investigation of the tulsa police
department for a couple different groups
of officers
and this thing just in my opinion it
steamrolled and
and got out of control pretty soon you
had bad guys that
were essentially being told by by the
fbi
um that was doing the investigation that
hey if you've got information on dirty
cops we can help you out with one of
your
we can help you out with your case if
they were already locked up hey we can
get you out of jail then people started
filing civil lawsuits
and it just started building up over a
year time period and
there were a handful different officers
whose names got brought up
some in fact did get arrested and go to
trial luckily for myself
i did not but i was labeled as what they
call an unindicted co-conspirator
and still something still to this day
that if you google my name it
occasionally pop up
and throughout my career i've had to
deal with that title and uh fighting it
every step of the way in court
well let me put this one way uh sean i
would say it's not
unlucky or luck it's innocence it's
obviously there's a reason why you
weren't arrested for that now in this
collection of stories is there one from
someone else
that stuck out to you even now as you
think back on your book
yeah absolutely you know i was fortunate
to talk with several different officers
across the country and these things
range from a simple traffic stop
to you know a guy who spent time in
prison for a murder he didn't commit
but one of them was a guy by the name of
clyde ray spencer it actually took place
in the 1980s
he was arrested and convicted for child
molestation of his own kids when they
were very very little
and he spent a little over 20 years in
prison and over that time it finally
came out
that the his ex-wife was having a sexual
affair
with the supervisor over the
investigating unit
dna evidence or what we call a sane exam
a sexual assault exam
that was never turned in it was held in
a detective's garage for nearly 20 years
and later magically appeared that would
have cleared him probably during trial
um so this poor guy spent you know i
think was a total like 21 years
in prison uh for a crime he never
committed
thank you for that sean make sure to
check out sean larkin's book which is
available now for pre-order
but of course is coming out on june 15th
still ahead on law and crime daily we
take you inside the courtroom of two
live trials we're following
capital gap but first a sneak peek into
the latest show featuring defendants
taking the stand
our interview with dan abrams after the
[Music]
[Music]
break
we're back a new series premiering on a
e is all about the courtroom
drama we often see it law and crime we
spoke with executive producer and host
dan abram who's also the founder of law
and crime network
to give an exclusive sneak preview let's
take a look at court cam presents
under oath it is incredibly rare for
criminal defendants to take the stance
real suspects accused of murder
it's a high stakes gamble very few take
delivering real testimony in their own
defense
we acquired the knife and the zip ties
never leave home without them will they
stand the pressure or fold
under oath you put the gun ventures from
his head
looks like extreme planning
original series under oath wednesday
june 2nd at 10
only on a e dan thanks for being with us
good to be with you brian pleasure now
dan what can we expect when we tune in
to the back-to-back premiere
of under oath this is a show about
defendants who
take the witness stand in murder trials
and as you know as well as anyone
it is very rare for a criminal defendant
much less a murder defendant
to take the stand in his or her own
defense it is an enormous risk
the whole case comes down to does the
jury believe this person's testimony
and so in each one of these episodes we
show you
what led to that decision why the person
has decided to risk it all
by taking the stand and then showing you
much of that person's testimony but also
interviewing some of the people who were
there at the time
to give us insight into what it was like
inside the courtroom
the decision to have the defendant take
the witness stand etc
so it's a high-stakes gamble and in each
and every episode
we show you that defendant on the
witness stand sounds like you basically
took
most offense attorneys and anxieties and
put it into a tv show
it's gonna be great now the interesting
part about this dan is under oath is
from the unique lens of the accused
as you take them through the case when
they take the stand talk to us about
the angle or the perspective of this
story yeah so we try and do
is not just say oh here's the defendant
who took the witness stand and here's
the video
uh of it what we try and do is explain
the circumstances surrounding it and
why the person decided to take the
witness stand we'll talk to
very often their lawyers sometimes by
the way we interviewed the defendant
him or herself about exactly
why that chance was taken why they they
decided to risk it all
and then show you of course what is the
the biggest part of this and you pointed
this out as a as a criminal defense
lawyer
the cross examination right that moment
everything seems like oh okay the direct
examination comes through
oh you see why they took the stand they
want to tell their story okay
but it all comes down to the cross
examination uh which
is the the most difficult part for any
defendant
particularly when you get a good tough
prosecutor asking the question
absolutely prosecutions always coming
tough with those cross-examination
because they very rarely get to defend
it on the stand so they enjoy it when
they do
now law and crime viewers should
recognize some of the cases
uh that you cover on under oath right
absolutely
um you know you'll see look some cases
that people will
remember like the jodi arias uh case for
example
but then you're gonna see other cases
like um you know two of the
cases that i think uh were the most
interesting uh both of which were long
crime stories with the tammy moore case
and the lindsay parton case both cases
of
women tammy moore accused of killing her
husband's
girlfriend and in the case of lindsay
parton a babysitter
accused of killing a three-year-old girl
in both of those cases one of the
reasons i found these to be the most
interesting cases
was because it was unclear whether they
did it
and there was a real question
about um you know well wouldn't they
not take the stand that tammy morris
sits up there and tells you
everything that she says happened so
those are the cases i i found to be the
most interesting
were the ones where it was really close
and the defendant's testimony
really made you say hmm you know i i
wonder
is is this person guilty or not
core camp presents under oath airs
wednesday on a e at 10 pm coming up on
lawn crime daily defensive testimony
from a former police detective
in the disappearance of robert durst's
first wife plus
jury selection now wrapped up in a trial
of a tennessee father accused of
murdering his five-year-old son
for the jurors will and won't hear at
trial next
welcome back a jury is now seated in the
upcoming tennessee trial
of a father accused of murdering his son
and hiding the body
three days after joseph daniels called
to report his five-year-old son with
autism as missing
police arrested daniels for murder the
tennessee bureau of investigation said
daniels confessed
during a five-hour interrogation to
hitting joe clyde daniels to make him
stop crying
yes sir he said he saw he said that joe
club was leading
a scratch on his leg and asked inquired
further
what that was from and mr dana said it
was from the proper table
but the defense says daniel suffers from
mental health issues and gave a false
confession
they say police didn't thoroughly
investigate as the boy's body has never
been found
at a pre-trial hearing the defense
suggested the boy could have been
abducted they called a local woman who
said their then
four-year-old daughter spotted a boy in
her grandmother's yard
the woman says her father lives there
and is a registered sex offender
the woman says her daughter told her she
asked the boy for his name
but he instead said he was five years
old she saw
a little boy walking down the road in
muddy in pajamas and he was talking to
her for a minute and then just
kept walking lauren says she filed a
police report but investigators never
did a thorough search of the property
the judge ruled the police report can't
come in at trial due to hearsay
unless the little girl who's now eight
years old testifies
and at another pre-trial hearing
prosecutors played a phone call the
defendant made to his father from jail
the defendant can be heard saying that
crystal daniels his wife
and the boy's mother killed their son
with a pillow daniel says she threatened
to kill him
if he told the truth
pull the knife
crystal daniels is charged with
aggravated child neglect or endangerment
and helping to cover up the crime shall
face a separate trial and her attorney
has said she'll plea the fifth
if called to testify in daniel's trial
all right terry let's dive into these
pre-trial arguments on one hand
the defense sounds geared to put an
eight-year-old on the stand
to point out to a completely different
suspect could that create reasonable
doubt for the
defense here it could brian but i really
think the defense is stretching this
argument here first of all
it was a four-year-old child at the time
and she's going to come in now a few
years later
stating that it could have been someone
else or
the whole point here is that the father
who was apparently in a
home there is a sex offender and that
didn't come to light
and so the defense wants to show that
had the police
investigated further that they would
have been able to determine that
information but
this four-year-old child is not going to
be able to remember what occurred and
her mother at the hearing
even said as much all right we'll see on
the other side
if the child did see baby joe then how
could daniel's jailhouse call make sense
what do you think the defense will do at
trial try one or the other
you know the call i think was really the
defendant trying to set up his wife
crystal because
it was just too convenient the father
was basically asking
the son who's the defendant whether or
not he did it
and the defendant is basically saying no
crystal did it i tried to stop her so
i think at trial we are going to see the
husband and wife
pointing at each other absolutely it's
probably the main reason why the two
cases are separated
the husband's going first the wife's
going afterwards we'll see how this
plays out for the prosecution and the
defense
when we come back the nypd detective is
standing by his investigation
into the disappearance of missing woman
kathy durst why it's being called into
question decades later
at a different murder trial next
welcome back prosecutors in california
say the disappearance of a millionaire's
wife
decades ago is the motive for the murder
of robert durst's best friend
robert durst is standing trial for the
december 2000 murder of crime writer
susan berman
investigators believe berman had
information about the still unsolved
disappearance
of kathy durst in new york 1982 and they
dirt shot her because she threatened to
go to the police
durst denies killing either woman the
nypd detective who investigated kathy's
disappearance was called to review his
original case file
michael struck is now retired but has
admitted on the stand in 2017
to having sex with one of the witnesses
in kathy's case that recorded testimony
was played for the jury
so strzok didn't have to fly across the
country for the trial
the headlines lawsuit claims nypd
covered up
jews do anything to cover up
their struggle with their loved ones in
his wife's
disappearance or personal death
[Music]
did you do your dead level best in your
investigation
yes prosecutors then asked the detective
about his first interview with robert
durst
after he reported kathy was missing the
detective says durst brought a copy of a
magazine
showing a photo of his father seymour
durst the real estate mogul
i wasn't impressed by it meant nothing
to me the uh
the name meant nothing to me who he was
in his family
the fact that he had magazine and i
recall
part of it
are there many things that you would
have done
back with us his co-host terry austin
terry the prosecution is trying to
strengthen their claim that durst had
something to do
with cassie's appearance was this
retired nypd officer's testimony solid
or
did the defense poke any holes you know
i think actually brian that they did
poke some holes
in the prosecution's argument look
they're trying to say that
not one body in the law enforcement
arena
thoroughly investigated they're saying
that the state handed it over to the
city
and no one pursued the leads and
everyone dropped the baton
everyone actually believed durst when he
said
he dropped kathy at the train station so
they were all
looking for that lead and so i
definitely think that
the defense poked some holes in the
prosecution's argument there because
they should have followed up
with the prime suspect who is robert
durst always you look at the individual
closest to the victim and they did not
do that here
absolutely now terry words are part of
the testimony probably a really big part
but how did the officer come off to the
jury he was there
when they tried to find kathy durs's
real killer
but basically they're saying that he
messed up in the past so how did he take
that
you know i think he was credible i think
the jury probably liked him even though
they're watching this over a video at
this point in time
because he has no bias he has no reason
to lie but he failed to follow up some
good leads so that's a problem
absolutely terry thank you and thank you
for joining us here at long crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you